[Music]
hi everyone thank you for joining us my
name is Kiera Pandya I'm a technical
lead on partner engineering for machine
learning at Google cloud and the topic
we're gonna cover today is how do you
automate invoice management right well
you're every business practically has
invoices that they're either paying or
sending out and these are pieces of
paper and how do you how do you automate
that using machine learning alright so
going back to the roots why are we here
what is the goal the goal at the end of
the day for Google here is to
democratize AI we want to take all these
bleeding edge innovations in artificial
intelligence that our research teams
Google brain are coming up with and
making them available to your businesses
right to to make it so that instead of
needing one of the thousands of data
scientists globally one of the millions
of developers globally can then use the
same technologies that's the goal here
and with that in mind the the question
we have to ask ourselves is what given
the limited resources we have every
organization at the end has limited
resources how do we target our resources
to get the most ROI for everyone
involved not just us our customers our
partners and what that leads us to is
the question of unstructured data so one
of the one of the very sort of
interesting pieces of I guess statistics
or whatever that a lot of people don't
realize is that upwards of 90% of
enterprise data is unstructured it's all
those emails it's all those Word
documents it's all those those text
files it's all those PDFs sitting in
accounting that's all unstructured data
and the challenge with unstructured data
is not only is it abundant it's hard
they're you think a structured data you
think of a database right you need
average CTO goes oh yeah I have XYZ
amount of petabytes in databases and the
way you access that is easy you write a
bunch of sequel queries or there's a
standard ecosystem that everybody
reaches for of tools but if I gave you a
chunk of unstructured data and say
go get me answers there's no clear
answer there is no standard set of tools
that you're gonna use someone's gonna
reach for you no regular expressions or
you know some of those things but what
we're doing here now is applying em out
and the idea is that machine learning
can vary has it has a very clear path to
making sense of unstructured massive
volumes of data part two of the story is
the transformations coming right
businesses used to be run like this this
is what we're moving to and you should
have started your journey a while ago
but if you haven't that's still okay you
can still do it now right and the theme
underlying team here is the
announcements you saw around Auto ml
right all these cutting-edge
technologies you can apply them to your
business to your existing business
process as you are on this journey of
transformation so the announcement this
morning was about Iron Mountain and our
partnership there and what are we doing
here the goal is to advance automated
document understanding we're working
with Iron Mountain to with their
customers permission digitized data and
derive understanding from it so all that
dark data that's sitting stored away
from years of Records literally the US
corporate history right of the Fortune
1000 extracting valuable today dark data
using machine learning but as all these
presentations go right the ml guy comes
on stage and goes on about how ml is
gonna change the world in the future
we'll get there that's true but let's
talk about here now how can you use the
tools we talked about this morning and
all day today and throughout next Auto
ml and machine vision to to automate an
existing process so this is about here
and now this is something that you can
start using today so as one of the
scenarios in the thousands we could
tackle with how businesses deal with
documents the one that seems to impact
the most number of businesses is hey I
get I buy stuff as a part of doing
business I
people money or I sell stuff and people
owe me money and these documents need to
be processed we've been doing that since
1860 this is actually an actual invoice
from 1860 and this is a modern one
nothing's really changed and the reason
it hasn't changed is the computer
science behind making a protocol packet
to have two computers talked about hey
you owe me X is easy but there are too
many players the structure of that
packet cannot be agreed upon so what
we've done is we've sort of fallen back
to well we have accounts receiving an
invoice the invoice team has people that
look at it and approve it and it's a you
know it's a human intervention process
so let's change that right so what does
it mean to do document understanding
right at ten thousand feet the thing
people usually jump to is oh this is OCR
this is not just OCR OCR is optical
character recognition literally the
hello world of machine learning for any
new learning data scientists is a
dataset called M nest and this data set
is understanding characters it's
literally the hello world of the
industry what we're talking about here
is going from that extracted text to to
recreating the structure that is a
parent to a human that's reading the
document recreating that structure and
then putting it into a system that
manages structured data and it's part of
a business process right that is truly
document understanding and at 10,000
feet as these three steps and where OCR
is literally just step one okay so let's
talk about each of the pieces step one
you extract the text so google has the
cloud vision API this API is solves
computer vision challenges and problems
that are general in nature right it's
not going to identify my business's
widget a versus widget B but if you want
to you know identify a ship versus a
boat right it can do that because
there's a general problem it impacts
everything this is the technology that
backs Google's efforts in search
part of this offering is an offering to
do OCR so when you use Google search
we're not just looking at the metadata
around the search right we're looking
into the images to find your relevant
images so the technology that powers
that is also what powers are the
division API to do OCR so okay we have
step one we give it an image it gives us
the text part two of this is that the
pricing here is a game changer
I'll let the slide speak for itself
honestly but it's pennies on the dollar
and one of the keys sort of friction
points in business right there's a
reason it's hard to structure businesses
on a one dollar transaction because the
transaction fee completely kills any
margin you have so as you're trying to
reduce your cost of transactions reduce
the friction of transactions this
becomes very important so this basically
makes the cost of transactions pennies
on the dollar all right step two so we
got the text out of the document now we
got to restructure it we said we're
gonna apply machine learning that's
great now you're gonna need a data
scientist and this person will go away
for six months eight months and come
back with a model in that period you
will have spent lots and lots of money
lots of lots of time lots of lots of
engineering and lots and lots of
organizational focus on solving this
problem where each of these is a very
complex problem in itself that engineers
specialize in so we go back to our first
principles my first principles are
that's not okay we need to make this
technology available and accessible to
every developer so we have auto ml the
idea behind auto ml is that all of this
becomes one click it becomes one API
call you give it the data you give it
the data set and you tell it go train
and in a couple hours it comes back to
you with the model that will have
best-in-class accuracy and
then it gives you again a one API call
way to say go host this in a scalable
way for me so that I can just make
requests to it and I don't have to worry
about well I need the right
infrastructure to do low latency
inference on my model none of that you
don't have to worry about it you just
tell us and we host it for you so what
does Auto ml vision do in this case auto
ml vision is what's in the in the
parlance called a classifier it builds
you a classifier you give it classes of
training data let's say hey here's a
bunch of pictures of handbags shoes and
hats and you train it and then at the
end of the day it can it gives you a
model that when you give it a picture of
a shoe even when it hasn't seen before
but it's a shoe a human would recognize
that as a shoe it'll tell you this is a
shoe in concept pretty straightforward
in implementation billions of dollars of
research so I said you know it's gonna
give you one of the best most
best-in-class models auto ml produces
more accurate models with fewer
parameters and practically all the other
what I would call sort of benchmark
vision models today so you've got
inception before you've got ResNet 152
res next 101 BG 16 and you can see the
red line with Auto ml on top where
depending on how much time and energy
spent on training it you get more and
more accuracy with fewer and fewer
parameters now why do that why does this
matter this matters because because you
I know what you're thinking but well if
Google's gonna do it then it doesn't
matter it matters in latency and compute
cost at inference time so once the model
is built you're gonna make hundreds of
thousands of requests over time against
it so if a model has ten percent more
parameters in it you're doing 10 percent
more compute across hundreds and
thousands of requests so this is
important the other reason it's
important that's what that was sort of
this axis the other reason it's
important this axis is that if you get
it wrong either your business process
has a problem down the line or now you
have to employ the person that you freed
up to do a better task than just
scanning an invoice is now back in the
loop to make sure that the computer does
screw up right so that's not okay -
hence this is important so a little bit
of sort of technical arada about auto ml
so that the technology powering auto ml
is called learn to learn where we've got
a neural network that is effectively
watching that the model built being
built for you being trained and tweaking
the training process as it goes so
effectively
sounds like a buzz word I get it but
it's literally a model building another
model is what's going on and that's
called learning to learn and then along
with that we're doing large-scale hyper
parameter tuning to give you that that
super accurate model without you having
to do any work if you want to discuss
the internals of this we can then
probably here after - we can we can geek
out so next up we got so we got the
piece for extracting the text we got the
piece for well vaguely we have this
thing that does a classifier those are
our two tools in our vision box how do
we put this all together I promise that
the solution here would plug into an
existing business process right where
you're not throwing everything away it's
connecting to something real that you're
using today so what I'd like to do is
invite one of our partners up one of the
ways that Google makes these things real
as we work with our partners and our
partners really understand how each
business is special in its own way right
Google Google builds the the surgeon's
tool set if you will right to stretch an
analogy and then our partners are the
surgeons who take those tool sets and
make them do the surgeries make it real
and so in that in that vein I'd like to
invite Chandra from Deloitte to come and
talk to us about how they put these
things together to solve the invoice
management problem thank you yeah thank
you Karen can you hear me okay okay good
so our amazing technology right machine
learning now with a new announcement of
Auto ml from Safeway you must have heard
yesterday so what do we why do we why
does Google need partners right Deloitte
as a system integrator we are very close
to the business we understand each
industry we understand the big different
business challenges in every line of
business and we take this technology and
then we implement solutions which are
very relevant for every every every
company every industry every business
process and the lot has been working
with Google for multiple years now
whether it's in the in the form of
infrastructure as a service with us in
the form of analytics using bigquery
whether it's in the form of Adsense for
creating a new marketing platform for
our customers to get more insights and
obviously auto ml before auto ml was
announced it was available to us as a
partner in a bit of beta form but we
realized the power of ml just ml without
Auto ml very earlier on and we realize
that many of our customers can leverage
a true benefit which is extremely cost
effective it can be implemented in agile
manner not wait for six months or a year
to see the value so we started working
with the googles machine learning team
and the infrastructure team to develop
this solution so let me walk you through
it right so now every company right
whether you you do services whether you
manufacture goods you have to process
invoices right to pay your vendors on
time it's part of your and every vendor
is unique because they all have their
own branding they want they have a
different structure different layout
right so we need to be able to extract
the invoice get the business data where
it's a material number quantity amount
address you want to make sure it goes to
the right address so all this business
information which is in different format
for every vendor has to be extract in a
very accurate form and before a
financial document is created right so
very crucial business process and let me
share with you until now
companies whether it's a midsize company
or large sales companies spend millions
of dollars with the commercial
off-the-shelf solutions from different
vendors to do the vendor inverse
management which easily cost anywhere
from two to four million dollar just
from licensing now on top of that add
few months of implementation testing
with your ERP now every time a year B
goes through a software change and you
again have to go back to that inverse
management soul
do some testing do some remediation
every time a new vendor is incorporated
to your business you have to go through
the programming all over again because
they may have a completely different
logo completely different format so it's
a very very slow process very very
expensive process and it does not
leverage any benefits of cloud computing
and machine learning and plus on top of
all of this it has a very high sunk cost
right
whether you use all the features of your
invoice management solution or not you
have to buy all of it and you have to
spend millions of dollars upfront so
that is why we developed this solution
Deloitte has developed this proprietary
solution for automated invoice
management for your s4 Anna ERP system
so s4 HANA is sa piece large enterprise
resource planning solution and we have
developed this because we know ASAP s
winona in detail we understand the
business processes so it's going to help
us obviously alternate your invoice
management it's going to make it more
efficient it's going to be much faster
lifecycle from a solution perspective to
ask an invoices post it to the business
documents and obviously adopt it as you
go so let's walk through a little bit in
detail about the different components
that are involved so as you see as you
heard from Corrado obviously machine
learning is a very crucial component
along with the vision API those are the
building blocks of scanning the invoice
right to make sure we extract the right
data so our developers who are very well
form well-informed about machine
learning and the coding required so we
we develop our code around these two
technologies then it has an cloud
storage to store these invoices because
every customer scans roughly you know
anywhere from few thousand to several
hundred thousand invoices on a monthly
or quarterly basis a lot of money right
and you do it most of the time in a
batch mode right for most customers and
the room for error is very small because
you don't want to get an invoice
inaccurately scan which which could be
for thousands of dollars to a wrong
vendor so there's a lot of money at
stake it's a real business problem right
so cloud storage helps us to store all
those invoices for audit compliance
perspect
for much longer period at a very very
lower cost and plus is available
everywhere in the world as long as you
have a cell phone or a laptop and
obviously is for Hana which is your
business system which will take that
invoice right and then post it to the
make - for financial document so now I'm
going to invite Sudha or who's my
colleague who's gonna decompose this
architecture for you I'll help you
through each of each and every process
step by step how do we scan the invoice
how do we get the OCR data how do how
does the AP clerk gets to review that
data and then post it in ASAP so that
over to you thank you Chandra good
afternoon everyone I'm so Dockery
I am the global ACPs for Hana center of
excellence lead at Deloitte and we've
been working very closely with Google on
building the solution so I wanted to
take a step further get into the real
details and kind of help you understand
what the solution is I mean what
components are involved details awarded
and followed by a demo so it just cannot
get started so there are essentially
three steps three main steps to the
solution the step number one is
uploading of invoice it's kind of
obvious right so you have your invoices
which which need to be scanned and
uploaded one important information for
you to note here is that the invoices
that are uploaded are stored in Google
Cloud storage which is obviously running
on Google cloud platform and the
scanning of invoices can either be done
from your laptops mobile phone or any
device so all those capabilities are
built in now the third important thing
for you to kind of flow is when you when
you talk about invoice management you're
obviously talking volume so you'd every
customer any carpet customer would have
tens and thousands of invoices that get
uploaded every day so so that's where
the upload functionality comes in now
next important part is the intelligent
extraction of these invoices
so you have got these invoices which
uploaded and ready how do you actually
understand the information there and
there are again three steps to this
intelligent text extraction the step
number one is you should using the
vision API to actually extract the
detail from the invoice right so as for
that we are using Google's machine
learning vision API extremely capable
API tool there we have seen it work with
different kinds of invoices and when
invoices often have scribble text text
manually written all those kind of
invoices also work extremely well with
the vision API then the next component
is how do you know now you have
extracted the details how do you know
what information is there so for that
you vote you have we have yeah Mel
config which kind of comes into play
which helps as an understanding what
information is where in the invoice so
that's step number two now the third
thing is you have extracted the
information how do you know that this
particular invoice belongs to a is a
template from a particular vendor this
how do you connect this that's where the
third component which is auto AML comes
in and then we develop the solution
we've been developing that that over a
period of time we had used traditional
ml and we also used auto ml and once we
started using auto ml we actually saw
that there was a good increase in
confidence percentage so when I show you
the demo you would actually get a peek
at it but with Auto ml we were really
able to enhance the solution so with
combination of these three extraction of
the solution and then come
classification of a solution you are
actually able to take this unstructured
data and convert it into a more
structured data now the third component
here is now we have extracted invoice we
have all the information this
information is posted into s AP and it's
not just plain posting of invoice that
I'm talking about they also business
rules validations and checks that come
into picture and
close to kind of make sure that the data
that is getting uploaded is in fact
actually and is business-ready
so those are the really the three
components which come into play in this
whole process so a morado kind of get
you guys a little bit of a visual feel
of of how this is happening so what you
see in the background is how the text
extraction is working this is where the
visual API is looking at the components
of the invoice and then it is extracting
all the information which is there than
invoice in different blocks as you can
see over here okay so once the
extraction is done then Yaman config
kind of comes into picture this is like
a really use really user-friendly and I
would say easy to understand where you
would you would look at the invoice and
you're able to see what information is
where in the invoice now let's get to
the third part which is the cool part
which is now you've got you have
extracted the information on the invoice
how are you actually going to identify
that this information belongs to it is
corresponds to this particular template
and that's when auto ml comes in so as
you can see here there are three
different invoices tariffs completely
different format from three different
vendors so all this information is
getting fed into auto ml and when a new
invoice comes in you are able to
identify that this invoice is
corresponds to this particular template
so I mean that's how the whole thing is
working we have trained the model with
with multiple invoices and really good
results that we were able to see and
that's what I wanted to show you once we
get into the demo mode I think that's
pretty much it let's so let's quickly
switch to the demo yeah okay thank you
okay so let me introduce the screen a
little bit to those of you who are not
very familiar with ACP actually a quick
show of hands how many of you have used
sa PRS
be customers of you know how interacted
with have worked with sa P okay
yeah okay thank you but can I'm gives me
an idea so so this is for those of you
who do not know this is called s CP
Fiore tiles these Styles essentially
called us this is us a piece new user
interface and the tiles are called as
the fury tiles really convenient easy to
use and we have developed this user
interface using sa piece cloud platform
so what you're seeing essentially here
is s ap cloud platform there so the step
number one that we have here is scanning
of invoice like how I explained so we
take these invoices we scan them this
the demo would show you the invoices in
online mode but this can very well be
batched when we are using tens and
thousands of invoices so these are the
different components we have got the
scanned invoice and I also wanted you to
look at the Google Cloud Storage where
this invoice actually gets stored okay
so here is a look at the invoice that we
actually gonna upload so I'm going to
take one invoice we'll take it all the
way through then I can show you another
invoice which is in a completely
different format as well so take the
invoice a more clear or located
so all the information there we have got
the item details so we get into the the
cloud platform screen a quick button
there which we click on and we select
the invoice and it's all successfully
uploaded so once this is a uploaded you
can actually go to the cloud platforms
and you should be able to look at the
invoice as well so this is what this is
where it does all the invoices are going
and sitting in the in the background
next is a viewing of a scan invoices
okay I want to pause here and kind of
explain you this screen a little bit so
what just happened is we had the invoice
which we scanned there and put it in
Google Cloud Storage now in the lookup
in wire screen that invoice shows up
right and what you're seeing over here
is the extracted information from the
invoice the third screen as a as I play
is the actual image of the invoice so so
once we click on the next button
yeah so this is the header details of
invoice there you see the confidence
percentage 95 which quickly flashed
there that actually shows that improved
percentage that we got once we started
using auto ml so this is the invoice
that we scan all the information there
and let me just pause over here so that
we can actually absorb this information
completely the left was invoice that God
uploaded and towards the right is the
actual invoice that that was uploaded
and what you see here in the middle is
the information that God extracted from
this invoice and is now right over here
right so this is the three-step very
very I would say intuitive user
interface another important point I want
to really emphasize is I am showing you
this whole entire thing in an online
mode but when you are dealing with tens
and thousands of invoices you would
actually bash this so this is not I mean
you you wouldn't really be clicking on a
submit when processing these invoices
what you will essentially do is we have
the confidence percentages the
thresholds which you can set for example
you can say that anything over 93% or
95% whatever you may all those invoices
would go through automatically if it's
less than that then then potentially you
can manually look at those invoices so
those kind of thresholds and parameters
can be sent to make
a much more automated process so the POA
information the details are kind of
there
that's the key yeah once we come back in
the item information the confidence
percentage again are really good there
we click on submit so here is what
happens as soon as you click on submit I
want to pause here on a cut-off so this
is the invoice number of the invoice
which is actually posted in SA P right
so this invoice immediately is kind of
going in and posting in SA P so I said
she'd what we do is the screen that you
saw previously is the link now this is
out of box F ap app Fiore app which is
provided for supplier invoices so the
inverse that we just created
automatically got posted in SA P so
getting to that screen and looking at
this particular invoice let me continue
so the invoice which we copied and
pasted it there you see the document is
already posted we can get into sa P you
can look at the invoice the item details
tax payment all everything got populated
and even the attachment is also there so
this is the invoice as you recall it is
is what we had uploaded
yep okay so I know that yeah so so the
the previous screen that we saw was a si
ps4 on a screen I know that many of you
are ECC customers as well so we also
wanted to kind of show this that the
same thing the the invoice that is
created is posted in the backend as well
to kind of get get you to see how the
ECC user interface or the backend GUI
would look like the same invoice we put
that in and you're able to get in into
that and same information you see in the
backend
ASAP back end to the item details
everything accurate you have the vendor
details as well and then now we are able
to look at the attachment so click on
the attachment list it takes you to the
attachment there open it and then there
you go that's the image that you just
scanned and uploaded
yeah
if we wanted to kind of get in and show
the process for a different invoice as
well I mean here is another invoice and
I will try to kind of quickly run
through so that you get a feel it off so
this is the invoice again similar
process getting in uploading the invoice
and you would see that
this this a completely different invoice
with a completely different format again
we were able to upload to the same
application is able to read is able to
understand right so this was pretty much
it I mean this is this is really the
crux of the solution if you want to see
a live demo of it we are showing a live
demo of it in our Deloitte booth you're
most welcome to come in and then get a
live look and feel of how the solution
is looking so at this point of time I
wanted to hand it over to kirat to
conclude thank you sue that can we
switch back to the slides please
all right so what did you just see you
saw in summary we did the three pieces
right we extracted the text we
restructured it back to some a form that
is expected by again tying it all
together to an existing business process
system so the takeaway from all of this
is that the technology you're seeing
being announced all around you here it's
all MLA I oh my god it's the future it's
real today you can connect these like ml
people like to do demos like hot dog not
hot dog show you these abstract things
right and my goal here if you take away
one thing is that this tech can be
applied to your existing business
process today all it takes is a little
creative thinking around okay well what
is a painful point that I deal with
every day that is either that either
needs lots of human people doing a light
touch sort of yes or no yes or no or is
it just a very pro you know steps
through process that just involves
understanding unstructured data those
kinds of problems are solvable today you
just have to sort of sit down and think
about wait a minute what if I were to
apply ml to this problem how would I
solve it
[Music]